Do you believe in ghosts?
Rationally, no.
But in spooky surroundings, well...
We were discussing ghostly experiences in my  psychology class.
A friend of mine told us about a laughing ghost...
...that sits on the chests of young Asian males,...
...suffocating them if they can't push  the demon off.
Evidently, this ghost only has it in for any young males...
...with Asian blood in them.
He asked with all seriousness,...
..."Hasn't it ever happened to you?"
I laughed and asked him if I was in danger because of my Asian blood.
He looked at me with fear and said,...
..."It happened to me a couple of nights ago...
...and I bet he's still around, watch out."
Never had I gotten such a good laugh!
In fact, this phenomenon is very common and is known as sleep paralysis.
It's important for your body to not move too much while you are asleep...
...because you might hurt yourself.
But sometimes if you wake up...
...before your body can recover from this state...
... or if you are having strong clear dreams,...
...you may sense a heavy pressure on your chest...
...and feel as if you cannot move.
Just remember, it's not a ghost!
It is something that can happen to anyone anytime they are asleep.
Every culture in the world...
...has different ways of talking about this phenomenon.
The Chinese call it the "bed press ghost".
In the West, it is known as the "scissors lock" ...
...which is a kind of wrestling move.